from the perspective of the startup
i was always kind of skeptical of
raising money
it feels like people do it too quickly
too easily
but i don't know what the hell i'm
talking about
when is the when should a startup raise
money
and from the perspective of the investor
when should the
investor invest in a startup like is
there a timing thing here is there
um what yeah it's a very important
question because
the venture capital community is only
going to fund
you know sub one percent of enterprises
start in the in the united states every
year like
maybe ten basis points of them like one
in a thousand
and the reason is it's jet fuel
you only want to take that money if you
really want to build something big and
you want to build it fast
and when you put jet fuel behind a
startup
as we've seen with other rockets things
can blow up and people can die
you know it's not people literally dying
but the business can go up and smoke
right like rockets get blown up all the
time at spacex
as part of their ambitious plans and
startups seven out of ten startups we
invest in
go to zero now if you were to start the
business and only build it off customer
revenue and use your own money and go
nice and slow and grow 10
a year the chances of you blowing up the
rocket
are very low because you're riding a
bicycle
you can go a little faster but the
bicycle can only go so fast
and once you start taking that money the
way the portfol
the way venture capital is constructed
as
a in the mix of like mit or harvard's
endowments is
you know we're gonna put some money into
uh safe things and then we're gonna have
these really binary things over here
and they probably put five percent uh
in venture capital traditionally it's
grown to 20 just as a function of how
successful it's been
so you know the harvards of the world
and mit is probably one five or
ten percent in venture but it's grown to
25
because you know companies like airbnb
and uber have grown so big in tesla
but the goal is in these venture funds
we're going to invest in 30 names
and one or two of them are going to
return three times the capital we've
deployed
so it's a 300 million dollar fund and
there's 30 names and each got 10 million
that means one of the 10 million is
going to return
the fund plus so that means it has to
grow
30x and then 60x to double the fund
and you're really supposed to be doing
three times cash on cash so that 300
million dollar funds
the expectation is in 10 years to return
900 billion
triple the person's money as opposed to
the stock market which doubles your
money in the same period
so you're supposed to do 25 annualized
returns in order to
triple the money and maybe i have an
outlying chance of four or five times
the money which does happen sometimes
when you have an outlier in your
portfolio like uber or facebook was
and what that means is the venture
capitalist behavior and the game they're
playing is different than you as the
founder you as the founder you may
really care about this
and it dying really matters to you and
then you've got a venture capitalist
who's like we're betting on 30 names we
need two of them
to hit it out of the park maybe three
and nothing else is meaningful
so now you start thinking about the game
theory there
you're dealing with you know money that
is coming in
that only cares about you going 100x
yes it's a whole different ball game
whereas if you build off revenue you
don't have to do that and if you look at
a company like com.com
we invested at 5 million the next round
they did was 250 they were so capital
efficient
that they grew from 10 000 a month in
revenue to millions of dollars a month
in revenue
over those four years since we invested
and they didn't raise money in between
wow it was unbelievable and i've only
seen this happen three or four times so
it doesn't happen all this capital
efficient meaning
uh based on customer revenue alone plus
some
small amount of fundraising yeah you're
able to go like
how hard is it to do that it takes
extreme product market fit you have to
have a great price for your product that
has a great margin
um yeah and if you're doing something in
hardware
it's probably impossible because it's
super capital intensive so it's probably
got to be a software business
software hardware businesses take a lot
more do venture capitals get in the way
at all of the business or do so it
depends to get out of the way
yeah if you if you get young venture
capitalists who are starting their
career
they're very nervous and scared because
they're putting all these bets
yeah and then there's a very weird thing
that happens
the bad news comes first so yeah
companies that don't work out go out of
business immediately
yes so if it's not going to be com or
robinhood or uber
those take sev you know you have a one
of those great successes somewhere in
your five six seven eight as an investor
what is the first five years like the
first five years you feel like an idiot
because you let's say you make these uh
10 bets
in year two two or three of them come
back and they don't have product market
fit and they're out of money
and they say can we have more money you
say no we have to go get it from
somebody else because you have to prove
that there's still a market for it
we may keep our pro rata we may put a
little bit in to maintain our percentage
ownership
but we're not going to give you another
big chunk of money yes
and that company dies so now you've got
10 million poof up in smoke boom
10 million up smoke so this is called
the j curve where
your performance goes down and then it's
only in years four five and six it
starts going up
and what you're seeing right now is the
people who started like i did in 2000
you know just 11 12 years ago in 2009 i
started investing
we all look like geniuses why we're at
the end of the cycle
we invested after when the stock market
was on the floor after the financial
crisis
and it's gone straight up since so
everybody look there's a couple little
blips in there but
generally speaking there hasn't been
like a major crash uh with the exception
of the pandemic crash but that bounced
right back
and so you know it takes a decade to
figure out if you're good at it
and then if the market crashes again
everybody feels like and again the cycle
starts again so
you are now as a founder you are now
inserting yourself into that casino
yes and now you've got all these other
forces pushing and pulling
and you're growing let's say your
company was growing 50
you feel like wow i'm successful i made
a million dollars last year and now i'm
doing a million and a half
and and the first thing that vc is going
to say is how do we triple we're
we're growing too slow see but that's
like you said that beautifully uh is a
rocket fuel
it's uh in in the sense it's a kind of
motivation it's a dry i mean
it's a positive so if you want that yes
if you want that
if you want that if you want to go to
navy seal school
you're going to be in pain and they're
going to put that hose in your face
while you're underwater with your hands
tied behind your back in the pool and
you're gonna be choking
and you might have to do cpr and you in
like every couple of years
tragically somebody dies in navy sales
school
yeah well it doesn't mean we're getting
rid of the navy seals rocky if he dies
he dies
you